denmark has lifted all domestic pandemic
restrictions the first european union
member nation to do so the government
credits a high vaccination rate for the
move but warns that measures could come
back if necessary danes have reacted
with both caution and optimism as public
spaces roar back to life
fun is back in denmark families are
flocking to the famous tivoli amusement
park in copenhagen as if corona had
never existed and this father is glad
the government has put an end to the
roller coaster of restrictions i believe
that they've handled it from
the intention of doing it best possible
so i think
on the whole i think they've done well
and with schools fully open again
mothers like here feel nothing but
relief despite some remaining risks they
don't get as ill as their dolls and they
don't get as many
symptoms afterwards so i think it's okay
i would rather send them to school than
have them home
but not everyone is so relaxed even when
raising a glass to their meeting on a
sunny terrace but i think it's too early
to be happy about it
i think when winter comes it will
there will be problems
but with vaccine uptake high in denmark
the head of the copenhagen task force
says the time is right now that there
are so few non-vaccinated left those
that are not vaccinated now are perhaps
the skeptics some of them write to me
personally
daily often
about their concerns but
in percentages of the population they're
very few
eager for the doors of this nightclub to
reopen these young people have embraced
vaccinations
looking at pictures like that denmark's
leading virologist has some residual
doubts but he accepts reopening is also
a political necessity
it
does create some problems arguing that
corona is still
a threat to society with such a high
percentage of the population vaccinated
so i think the overall evaluation was
that it was better to
step down a little bit and then
should it increase then we could always
up it again meanwhile some are a bit
ambivalent between happiness and
apprehension i really have to get used
to it
so we just talked about it was like
should we go out tonight well we can go
out tonight like okay let's do it
first time for like two years almost
yeah that's crazy it's weird
but the authorities are not letting
their guard down completely they will
for instance test waste water to monitor
for future outbreaks of the virus and
their best defense the state is fully
digital and is seamlessly collecting
citizens data
we have a register of everybody who
tests positive in a laboratory with the
disease we also have a register of who's
vaccinated and we have regis a
population register so we know where
everybody lives and we can contact
people directly
and so for now danes can enjoy the last
of the summer and dive into their new
found freedom
you